But you can't do basic Google searches or ask basic questions.
>> GUYS, WHAT'S GOOGLE? WHAT IS GOOGLE? HOW DOES GOOGLE
WORK? HOW DO WE DO GOOGLE?
WAIT A MINUTE. THEY'RE here
and they're supposed to be here.
You've heard about the Papa Cut crash out of her Nick Shirley
video. Oh, no, I haven't. Hold on. What is this? Unhinged liberal
Papa Gut has a full meltdown at Sir Caleb Hammer over the Somali
scam story, falsely claiming he exposed Nick Shirley for lying
about an address. Papa Gut was completely wrong. He panics and
deletes the stream instantly in total embarrassment.
No way. What is this?
>> This is 607 and is not a transportation >> That's
crazy cuz the address isn't 607. It's 607 South. So this is where
they are right now, right? Uh this is where they're supposed
to be. He's not at the place. It's actually listed on the place.
He's He's dumb. He's an idiot. He doesn't know how to read directions
on maps. Safari. I just I I really just need to look at this
for this video. I don't care because we just figured out that
they're lying about the address. I need to know if Caleb Hammer
and their factchecking team of like 30 different employees were
able to figure out that they're at the wrong address because
they're at 607 and not 607 South. I need to know like how desperate
they are. See, the weird thing about this is I know. Maybe Papa
Gut doesn't know. He should know, though. You could be you could
get every single
positive benefit of the virtue signal here
just being like um
just being like questioning, right? You get all the anger, all
the like outrage on on the part of your audience. You're like,
"Hold on.
Didn't we like look this up? I could have sworn." But hold on,
maybe I'm wrong. Maybe I'm wrong, but didn't we look this up?
Like you get the same vibe entirely and you don't look like a
It's life hack right there. Okay. I can do exactly this. I can
be like, I know I I know this, but I'll always do it that way
because then if I am wrong, if which I am, it's me admitting
I'm capable of making mistakes. That's an easy life hack, man.
I if you listen, if you heard that, I've said exactly like that.
I've said things exactly like that before, right? No, but it's
like I am saying the honest truth. Like maybe I'm getting this
wrong. I could be getting this wrong, but you get the same outrage
and you don't look like a total >> are to guzzle conservative
propaganda. see any signs denoting that there's any trans why
like what do you do with your money? Do you just like shove it
up your ass or do you actually like spend it on people doing
your job? I'm sick of this [__] dude. What the is
this? Are you kidding me? That's crazy, man. That's crazy, dude.
This is crazy. It's crazy, bro. What the [__] IS
CRAZY, DUDE? YOU HAVE A This kid is a Nick Shirley's aard. He's
going around lying about the places he's going to and you sit
there and you go, "That's crazy. I'm just in the middle, guys.
I'm I'm cumg guzzling conservative propaganda because there's
no expectation from my audience to fact check anything at all.
Taking everything he's saying as a fact when he's not at the
correct location on the paper he shows us in the video. Are you
kidding me? You have employees
Caleb where >> Papaood is an idiot. It's the same play
>> you fail constantly.
Why didn't he just do a little drop down? Why didn't he just
do like a drop down guy and see if the like when you drop down,
don't you just see the same businesses there?
Shouldn't this be like really hard to up? Hold on. Hold on. Is
it AA Transit? Is that what they're looking for? 607 Cedar Avenue,
South Minapolis.
Wait, wait.
There's no way that's on his stream, is it? Is there
that? Like this is
that's not he him looking that up. Hold on. There's no plausible
way. Cedar Avenue South is the same as Okay, but hold on. If
we go there, can I go to here, please? I'm trying to go here.
Minneapolis. One second. Okay, we go here. I just like dropped
down onto the street or something. Okay, >> that they're
lying about this is actually I just I I really just need to look
at this for this video. I don't care because we just fig
like what do you do with your money? Do you just like shove it
up? >> Masha Allah restaurant number one. Yeah, I don't
see that here.
I don't see it there, Maps.
I was like, "Oh, I'll probably just see one of these things on
the street,
but I actually don't." So, interesting.
Maybe this is what fooled him, though. Maybe he did drop down
and because he didn't see any of the same storefronts.
So, what he's saying is, Gringle,
he's saying that if you don't include the 607
uh 607 seaters south, you actually get the wrong address. So
they're at the wrong place for this business. That's what he
thinks. Yeah, but I think I think maybe a multiple of these businesses
are just >> [__] ass or do you actually like
spend it on people doing your job? I'm sick of this, dude. What
the is this? Are you kidding me? That's crazy, man. That's crazy,
dude. This is crazy. It's crazy, bro. What the
It's crazy, dude. You have a this kid is a Nick Shirley's a he's
going around
>> uh I really need to know when Papa Gut decided to hate
on Caleb. I'm guessing that that is because of or started when
these guys started doing like random commentary and >> lying
about the places he's going to and you sit there and you go that's
>> like broadly if you just believe all of this you're
also just a [__] >> Crazy. I'm just in the
middle guys. I'm I'm cumg guzzling conservative propaganda because
there's no expectation from my audience to fact check anything
at all. Taking everything he's saying as a fact WHEN HE'S NOT
AT THE correct location on the paper he shows us in the video.
Are you kidding me? You have an employee like 30 employees, Caleb,
where you fail constantly to do basic
research as you guzzle this.
It's so crazy. This fraud is,
dude, is there a direct correlation between how libed up you
are and how much you think about sucking
just scarfing down all the time? There's like a direct correlation.
It's crazy.
I dude, it's it's wild. >> [__] crazy. Are
you kidding me? Are you kidding me? What the is this [__]
How do you feel like you are so weak? This is so weak. I don't
give a [__] if this is a disproportionate crash out.
I don't give a singular [__] This is weak. This is
pathetic. YOU ARE THE FAX GUY that sits down singular. How do
you feel like you are so weak? This is so weak. I don't give
a if this is a disproportionate crash out. I don't give a singular.
This is weak. This is This is weak. So, I don't give a if this
is a disproportionate crash out. I don't give a singular. This
>> I feel like I see a nipple like down here. They're like
very far down
the chest. I can't see it for sure. Some
stuff going on here. >> This is pathetic. YOU ARE THE FACTS
GUY THAT SITS down and you lecture a bunch of weird liberals
about how they can't spend their money correctly, but you can't
spend tens of millions of dollars to hire somebody to do a Google
search. That's insane. That is insane. You were You made a live
stream show.
I'm watching the shadows down here. I'm just watching down here
now.
It's like Bob from Fight Club.
It's wild. become gargle. Whatever narrative makes you more successful
and I don't even think it's about the money. I think you just
want people TO LIKE YOU. THAT'S GAY. Grow up. You want people
to like you. What are you stupid? Get your [__] together
and stop SUPPORTING LIES. THIS IS SO BASIC. IT'S GOOGLE SEARCHES,
DUDE. IT'S GOOGLE SEARCHES. IT'S GOOGLE SEARCHES. HOW HARD IS
A GOOGLE SEARCH? DUDE, this is This is particularly rough. It's
particularly rough. Oh Jesus. This is a This is a tough one,
man. This is He's going really, really,
really hard on this for something he is wrong. >> He's
at THE WRONG [__] PLACE.
>> I would want to see how do we know if he's wrong, right
or wrong here. >> I guess that's what this is trying to
show is that these two these two addresses are the same. That
Cedar Avenue South is just Cedar Avenue in >> HE'S AT THE
WRONG PLACE. IT'S A GOOGLE SEARCH. HOW MANY PEOPLE FAILED TO
GOOGLE SEARCH EVERY VIDEO? IS IT INTENTIONAL OR IS IT ON ACCIDENT?
The you put such a high expectation of success onto yourself
and then you fail to Google
Holy. That's crazy though, GUYS.
THAT'S CRAZY. I LOVE IT. I LOVE HOW CRAZY it is. I'm the BOTH
SIDES GUY. I CALL out extremism everywhere. Unless it's in front
of my face and I make money on it, THEN I DON'T CALL IT OUT CUZ
I DON'T GIVE A [__]
Because it's not about being right, it's about wanting to seem
>> That's what I was just going to go to. Substance is
I was going to say like you start looking at the background or
something, you might be able to tell if it is um >> I want
people to like me. I want people on Twitter to like me. A bunch
of losers who sit all day on the internet being racist to like
me. >> This is really funny. I'm sorry. I'm like entranced.
I'm not even commenting cuz like I'm just entranced by how hard
he's going off without double-checking.
I WANT RACISTS TO like me. Hey guys, LOOK AT ME. I'M A PICK me
Asian. I want racists to love me. This is insane. And you want
to know why I'm so angry? Cuz I'm embarrassing myself for thinking
that you are somebody worth being a friend with. But you can't
do basic Google. Well, it's not No, no, no, no. It's not south
road name. It's like a south designation from like the city.
Like it's the it's the south southern set of avenues. A lot of
places have like a split where you go from south to north, right?
When you have like a grid system in a city. That's what he's
like, that's what he thinks is happening is that it's like north
instead of south, but instead it's like they didn't list it and
it is just this one. 607 is like it's still the same place. It's
the correct address, I think. So, like it's it's not insane that
he's wrong. He's not like a complete He probably looked into
this himself and thought it was
But, uh but I listen, he's embarrassing himself significantly
right now. >> But you can't do basic Google searches or
ask basic questions, GUYS. WHAT'S GOOGLE? WHAT IS GOOGLE? HOW
DOES GOOGLE WORK? HOW DO WE DO GOOGLE?
WAIT A MINUTE. THEY'RE here
and they're supposed to be here.
Wait,
why is he looking up at
Wait. Oh no.
Why didn't you just look them up in the same thing, dude? Wait,
why is he switching them between Map Quest and Google Maps?
Oh, he Why is one on Google Maps and the other's on Map Quest?
Oh, this is this is worse than I thought it was.
>> Oh, no. They're supposed to be here. >> Oh god.
Dude, this might be really funny. If you look at his stream,
>> they're supposed to be here. WAIT A MINUTE. THEY'RE
HERE. AND THEY'RE SUPPOSED to be here.
>> Oh, they're the same place.
Oh my goodness,
dude. Why? Why would he use different ones for both? I'm so confused.
Hold on. No shot. These are the two These are the two comparisons.
No way.
No way,
dude. Cuz you see it bend up here, right? They're the exact same
map. And he's just crashing out because he didn't
Why?
Why would you do Oh, this is worse than I thought,
dude.
That's so much worse than I
Uh, that's that's got to be a kill shot
most a lot of people. That's got to be a kill shot for a lot
of people, right? Like I just Oh, this guy's ready to go off
so hard at the drop of a hat. Uh,
no. I think I think the buildings are just shaded differently
between Map Quest and Google Maps. Like they're just they don't
look the same size. It is the same. Like you see this little
hook above like Sixth Street South? You get the same little hook
in above Sixth Street South, but it like doesn't quite look the
same. So, he saw the different styling between the maps and thought
it was like a different place, but he but they are the same place.
And you could tell by Sixth Street how it bends up here. The
Hard Times Cafe up here. Oh, buddy. Oh, but why did you go to
Map Quest? You What are you doing? You're pathetic. This is ridiculous.
This is This is the sum of your content. This is what the sum
of your content has been, >> I feel like I just want to
Just imagine he's reacting to himself. That's basically what's
happening here, right? He's just reacting to himself. >> Worth
being a friend with, but you can't do basic Google searches or
ask basic questions. GUYS, WHAT'S GOOGLE? >> WHAT IS GOOGLE?
HOW DOES GOOGLE WORK? HOW DO WE DO GOOGLE?
>> WAIT A MINUTE. THEY'RE HERE AND THEY'RE SUPPOSED to
be here.
>> You What are you doing? You're pathetic.
Just [__] Hold on. We got to We got a real look at
this when you back there. Hold on. You [__] you.
Oh, I was totally right. I was totally right. You could see it
down. You could see it.
It's like It's like Bob in Fight Club. That's crazy. Papa Gut
has an abusive relationship with Caleb Hammer. He's been concerned
trolling him for months. Well, that's uh that's rough. Uh this
Papa Gut guy is kind of a Isn't he like a complete He's like
Ethan Klein pro Ethan Klein slop in the afternoon. Yeah, he's
still going. This is all his chat's fault as well for not stopping
this crapshoot. Bro, it's not the chat's job. No shot. No way.
Destin sucks. We don't give him that. It is not the chat's job
to prevent me from looking like a Okay, that's not on any of
you guys. If I look like a
That's on me.
Dude, could you imagine if I'm like chat? Why did
That's kind of like Aiden looking over at Tickers. Tickers, why
did you take my photo away? Dickers, why did you take MY PHOTO
AWAY?
NO, I CAN BE RESPONSIBLE FOR MY own actions. I'm good. I'm good,
dude.
Holy [__] >> What are you doing? You're pathetic.
This is ridiculous. This is This is the sum of your content.
This is what the sum of your content has been, Caleb. This is
what the sum of your content has been. Ever since you started
this live show, the sum of your content has been zero factchecking
and just being completely willfully willfully ignorant so that
you can get be popular or whatever you want. I defended the out
of you. Are you kidding me? And I wasn't wrong. I don't defend.
This would be rough. Now I say it's like career ending. It looks
bad.
As long as he just owns it after this, he'll be fine, right?
As long as he just comes out and goes like, "Okay, that was embarrassing.
I up unbelievably
like I instead of I'll just do better in the future." I think
I think but if he if there's any part of it where he doesn't
just like come out and own it if he had all
if he had all fights like taking ownership of that >> defend
people because I'm friends with him. But you want to know what
I'm sure apparently I let some of my bias leak through. What
h this >> No no I can't What kind of bias does this guy
have? It's just a weak man making times hard for everybody. Stop
being a weak man. >> This is another one though. Hold on.
I'm not I'm not going to stop cutting him off. But um shamelessly
deleted the VOD. Deleting the VOD's a rough one, too. You should
leave that up. That should be shame that you have to endure.
Okay,
endure it. Speaking of weak men, man, what the happened? Do you
understand that this isn't just online slop? This can have very
real consequences to the rest of the world of energy. It's the
wrong place. It's the wrong place. It's not the same place. I've
already showed that like five times. It's not the same place.
It's not the same place at all. It's not the same place. Just
to be absolutely clear.
So, I'm just letting you guys know it is not the same place.
I'll show >> Wait, what?
>> Consequences to the rest of the world of energy. It's
the wrong place. It's the wrong place. It's not the same place.
I've already showed that like five times. It's not the same place.
>> Oh, he privated while he was clipping. Oh, hold on.
But I think we have the full VOD, don't we?
I'm pretty sure we got the full VA of this. I saw some people
passing that full VOD around. I think I opened this full VOD
earlier today. Where's Full Vaude at? I I'm almost positive somebody
got that and they threw it up on Rumble.
Where's it at? Where is it at? Somebody's got this full VOD.
I saw somebody say they archived it. Give me a second. Somebody
got it. Somebody snapped up this archive. Come on. Come on. I'm
almost positive I saw it. The last 10 minutes of the full VOD
are audio only because the second he realized he's wrong, he
ended and deleted the stream. Okay. Okay. All >> It's not
the same place at all. It's not the same place. Just to be absolutely
>> So, I'm just letting you guys know it is not the same
place. I'll show it one more time. How is How is this the same
place? This is Cedar Avenue. Dude, I I think I'm going to start
banning you >> Oh, no. >> I think I have to start
banning all of you. This is South 6th Street. Am I
>> What are you talking about?
Dude, I'm dumb.
Damn, I just crashed out for nothing. Holy, DUDE, DUDE. >> HOW
DOES GOOGLE WORK?
>> What the [__] is the matter with you? Is
that what you centralize your life around? I'm [__]
I'm so crashed out right now.
>> If my wife saw this, she would tell me to stop.
>> She would tell me to stop. So, I'm going to stop. >> His
wife sounds >> cuz I've had conversations with her about
how disappointed I am in you. And she agrees, but she doesn't
think I should publicly burn a bridge. But I'm
Oh, that's amazing, dude. No way,
dude. His wife's like, "Hey, times are tough for us, sweetie.
You know, you could probably get some viewers off of these guys.
They're really popular right now. You shouldn't burn a bridge
with them." And he's like, "My wife said I shouldn't burn a bridge
with you, but you guys,
dude, just don't understand how to communicate to you that you
want to be liked."
Oh [__] This is going minute by minute. Oops. That's
weak.
Did any of the lies? I defended the out of you. Are you kidding
me? >> Back, didn't I? Ah, hold on. >> Stop being
a weak man. What the happened? Okay. Being a strong man isn't
about people liking you.
Oh, I want the conservatives on I want Elon Musk to really like
>> [__] Hold on. I got to see if I can find
where where we >> How many people are out of a job because
of this >> right here >> percent. How many kids are
not going to get their health care because of this or their transportation
or people with disabilities or old >> I totally lost it.
If you guys go back and look at the time if we go back in the
VOD can someone go back in the VOD real quick and just find the
time I was at with the wife crash out thing cuz I now I've lost
it. >> People how many people are out of a job because
of this reckless freezing of funds when this has been in discussion
for months. How many people are going to get negatively disaffected
cuz they're black? Cuz that's all it is. Nick Shirley thinks
every Somalian person's a pirate. Did you bother to watch him
say that on Andrew Callahan's video? You watch my content, but
it's apparently not the content that matters.
>> Did you watch Andrew do it? Did you watch me watch Andrew?
Did we watch any? Do you understand that this isn't just online
slop? This got very real consequences to the rest of the world.
>> Oh, hold on. You guys need >> to the rest of our
country.
I saw you on Twitter. Hey, >> how are you guys letting
me not show this guy's face while he crashes out? >> Donald
Trump, I'm open to see You're open to seeing Donald Trump, the
guy that wants to attack Greenland, the guy that's using ICE
to go after people and violate their their process, their first
amendment rights, the administration that's trying to strip Mark
Kelly
11512 really right here. >> Cuz I've had conversations
with her about how disappointed I am in you and she agrees, but
she doesn't think I should publicly burn a bridge. But I'm so
triggered on this, dude. Do you realize that they're justifying
sending in like different government butarently
that's trying to strip Mark Kelly of his veteran status because
he told officers, law enforcement agents that they don't have
to agree to illegal orders, violation of freedom of speech. That's
the guy you want to see. We're not This is like I don't know
how to communicate to these people that any of this stuff. Facts
doesn't work. Emotion doesn't work. What works? What works? What
makes you realize like, hey, you know what? We're having a sloppy
time, but this is some real here.
>> When do we get to the point where we realize this is
some real
that's going on? That this is these are real people that are
getting terrorized because they're black because they came from
Somalia. My family came from Germany. Your family came from some
Asian country. People's families have come People have come from
all different
Is Caleb Hammer Asian?
That's the That Dude, that's He truly He's the 56% meme. If he's
Asian, he is the 56% meme cuz I had no idea. I assume he was
some kind of Latino.
He's like literally the embodiment of the Amerramut right here.
Okay. Italy, Greece,
Poland. I have Polish.
>> Totally indecipherable
genetics right here. Nobody could possibly get >> family
and they live in and you know what? There's Polish communities
out where I live. And you know what? I live in New York. There's
there's Italian people who have dug them the mafia that's dug
themselves into different systems. Do you see me on every Italian
person every day? No. And it's not because they look white. It's
because I'm not a weak piece of [__] that justifies
white supremacists going around acting like fools. The weakest
people in the world are racial supremacists. They have nothing
to hold on to other than the fact >> he's managed to turn
these guys up their fact checks in the Nick Shirley video into
a rant about white supremacist. >> Their skin color makes
them feel good about themselves. They have nothing else of value
to offer anybody. So they go, >> wait. Papa Gut understands
that like law enforcement and regulators targeting Italians who
they think are doing fraud, like targeting fraud by looking disproportionately
at Italians might have been a good strategy in places in like
New York State, right?
While that's like unfortunate to say, unfortunately like they
had a higher propensity, they had organized crime. They were
taking things over through organized crime that like some focus
on that might have been
I'm a victim because of my skin color. And you're supporting
those people when you have a show that's about shaming people
for not spending less money and working harder at a job. Tell
these young men to get a trade job. We're down 500,000 electricians
estimated by next year. We don't get that commentary. We keep
it to ourselves. We stay quiet against the white supremacy. It's
scary because I want Twitter to like me. But when it comes to
>> Bro, I No. YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT the real You want to
know what the real unsung position is?
My position. Okay. I don't care about white supremacy.
There's There's You can't make anybody
like get hyped at saying I just don't care.
And I don't care. But nobody's going to Everybody's mad at me
when I say that. White supremacists get mad at me. Oh, you what?
You don't want to protect your own people? You don't want to
protect your own people?
Uh anti-racists get mad at me. Oh, you don't think racism is
A BIG DEAL? OH, YOU DON'T THINK RACISM IS IMPORTANT? OH, YOU
DON'T YOU DON'T WANT TO BE ANTI-RACIST? It's like, yeah, I don't
care. No, that's the real That's the real unsung hero. Okay.
The guy who's just like, yeah, I don't give a [__]
People getting
by the way, he's got a whole bunch of people who will watch him
for his take
on the streets cuz they're black and that's all the it is and
that's all the it's ever been. were crickets cuz that's why they're
getting harassed. Yeah, some of them are doing a fraud. That's
bad. It's being investigated, but they're getting attacked cuz
they're black. I don't see any investigations getting mainstream
headline news in Texas or Florida.
What's going on with that? Where's that going? Where's your coverage
of the Donald Trump's phone? That's fraud. He hasn't released
that yet. We don't get any of that. We don't get it. We're very
selective. We're selective in what we talk about. What we talk
about are stupid.
We support conspiracy theories and that we make fun of people
with silly hair on the internet because that's more important
right now. That's very important to us. That's very important
to make sure that we do that. That is what we need in the society
right now is more culture war. We don't need to call out the
lies. That's it. That's where we're at. >> Dude, his microphone
is struggling right now. Thank you for strangling his microphone
on the show. >> Don't forget CNC computer uh
numerical control when you talk about trades for those who are
interested in computers but still want to trade benefits. That's
a good that's a good point. I'll have to look into that. Thank
you for the $2 from Buller Aries. My life is yours. Thank you.
Thank you, >> dude. He is He's so out of breath right now.
He's like dying. >> Vintage. What's going on, brother?
Ballad. Thank you. I appreciate that.
Thank you for the $10 from I can't even pronounce your name.
Maga Tara Magnus. Sorry, dude. I'm burnt out. A lot of people
feel like uh feel like this. Papa, you don't uh you are right.
Don't let them guessing places. I appreciate that. I appreciate
that. Sorry, I'm trying to I'm trying to read all the
the fan funding.
Thank you. Thought that was enough spaghetti. When I had the
LLC, uh an LLC, our registered address was just a mailbox for
legal docs, not our place of operation restaurant. That's what
I was looking. Okay.
Well, again, it's the wrong address, but I appreciate what you're
saying. Thank you for the aimmon small gut from a blue banshee
is why I'm here. Papa, thank you. I appreciate that. Thank you
for $5 from Gunnar FR for real.
>> It's so much better that he farmed donos. You get to
see how this audience
right? That he farmed so many donos during that. Now you can
just laugh at how stupid they are. Oh my god. >> Dance
Caleb, man. But the address is at the right. Unfortunately, the
street names are the same. But I love energy. It's the wrong
place. It's the wrong place. It's not the same place. I've already
showed that like five times. It's not the same place. It's not
the same place at all. It's not the same place. Just be clear.
>> So, I'm just letting you guys know it is not the same
place. I'll show it one more time.
All right. We're going to move on to the video, but just for
reiteration,
this is the address that they are at. Okay. This is 607.
>> This is Cedar Avenue. This is where they're supposed
to be. Cedar Avenue
>> They're at their incorrect place. >> That's where
they're at. This is not where they're supposed to be.
>> This is not where they're supposed to
>> Keep saying it.
>> Different places to be absolutely clear.
>> Dude, he's just trailing off slowly. He's like slowly
getting further away from his microphone. Speaking less, realizing
just how badly
he is uh
he's realizing just how bad this looks like in retrospect. This
is very funny.
They're in the wrong spot. So, it's not the same place. >> Not
go through. Hold on. >> What?
How is the How is this the same place? This is Cedar Avenue,
dude. I I think I'm going to start banning you all. I think I
have to start banning all of you.
This is South Sixth Street. Am I crazy?
What are you talking about, dude? I'm
>> Damn. I just crashed out for nothing. >> WHAT?
THERE'S NO WAY HE ends that quickly.
There's no way that he ends that fast,
Do we go to Papa Gut updates? Oh boy. Can I cover this just off
the Shamu stuff or do we need to go find Papa Guts VOD from today
and cover everything? Cuz my god, the Papa Gut stuff was bad
yesterday and he went live and I do believe he just knelt today.
I think he just totally knelt. All right.
Papa Gut had a rough one. He had a rough he had a rough take.
It's It's uh It's not the best.
Okay.
You need Papa Gut's VOD? Okay. Okay. For now, let's do his >> Yeah,
man. So, I kind of woke up to this uh post that it looks like
the entirety of my incredibly pathetic and embarrassing crash
out. I mean, let's just be absolutely real for my stream yesterday.
Um, and
>> uh, after this we will follow up with part two of that
Chud segment, which is >> picking through that Nicholas
Yoryo viod to see what exactly is going on there. We'll see what's
going on. Okay,
>> we'll see what's up.
>> Uh, Bub Rob, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it, man. Thank you. Thank you. >> I kind of want to address
it. Um,
you know, there's three big things I'm not happy with myself
with and I'm going to go in like, you know, least severe to most
severe just just to get it out there. Uh, mostly an apology to
Caleb Hammer. I just want to I just have to I've already talked
to him privately, but I'm pretty sure he hadn't seen this yet.
And this is horrible. Like, I'm very upset with myself now. Um,
it's just a nasty person. What a piece of [__] I
am. So, I wanted to talk about that and kind of just clear it
out and get it out there and say my piece. Um,
and yeah, >> I could just imagine his wife when she watched
that first Wait, is he wearing the same shirt? No, it's a different
shirt. Dude, his his wife must be so upset. He like before he
goes into that rant, you know what? My wife tells me I should
try to like maintain this bridge. My wife tells me I should be
nicer about this, but you know what? I've had enough. And then
he just goes the [__] >> So, move on. I mean,
what else are we going to do? So, I uh had a stream
you know. I had a stream
where I was reacting to Nick Shirley's newest video. Absolute
banger from Shirley. Thank you so much, King. Um, keep it real,
King. You know what I mean? Uh, but okay, I got to stop being
>> dude, why is he trying to Why is he trying to What is
this?
What is this
>> In the stream, I had like, like I said, a pathetic embarrassing
crash out. Um, I went off on something that I was super wrong
about, too. And when I realized it, I I said something along
the lines of like, you know, oh, I just crashed out for nothing
and I turned the stream off and I put it on private. Obviously,
let's be real, hoping that it wouldn't people wouldn't see it.
It's an embarrassing moment, but they have. And, you know, that's
just kind of the way that things work uh on the internet. Um,
it's been a while since I've been
relevant enough to capture some of my streams. uh you know, if
I want to be more mainstream, I gotta be more productive and
intelligent about the way that I express myself. This is a pretty
big like, you know, uh like, hey, get your together. Um
it almost
I
Okay, you need to make a better decision. Are we going to analyze
any of the the
I who you are as a person that made you go in that direction
like that without really having an idea of what you were talking
about? feel selfish to be able to find a productive message out
of this like hey you have to keep your together but you know
anyway it is what it is so let me go through the three things
like why of what I'm ashamed of myself for again in least severe
to most severe and really just kind of explain myself as why
I had this problem cuz I've been thinking about it obviously
like all night I'm like what is wrong with me you know even >> yeah yeah
I don't know what he means by mainstream here I'm very confused
about what he means by mainstream
um he is like already tried to be mainstream in some way. Like
he has all of the like easily defensible positions. He has like
no there's no edge to him. Like he's already trying to be mainstream.
I actually don't know.
I don't know
what he's talking about here. Like I'm trying to be mainstream.
I'm trying to go mainstream. I'll never be mainstream. Like yeah,
I think you could just stop there. You don't have to worry about
that. If you've been holding something back because you think
you're going to go mainstream, it's not happening. >> And
if this didn't come out, I'm still like, what is wrong with me?
Like how did I do what I did? So, let me just kind of express
uh what I've been thinking about. Uh tier one is just uh the
crash out in general. You know, even if I was in the right, I'm
35 years old, dude. What is wrong with me? I'm going to have
like a I'm going to have a meltdown on a stream. That's just
Dude, that's probably the worst possible direction to have,
bro. Oh, he used to have a big audience on TikTok and after controversy,
he was never able to get as big an audience on YouTube. Oh, what
was the controversy? But in any case, bro, that was that was
entertaining. If you were correct, that was like actually being
entertaining. What are you talking about? He's just totally wrong
here. No, you should talk with that much emotion. You should
talk with that much energy. You just need the energy to be focused
in the right direction. You need to not be a
What is he was his takeaway from that? Man, I should really stop
trying to be entertaining. Actually, that seems to be his first
takeaway, guys. Tier one. First takeaway, don't try to be entertaining.
Don't try to be emotional. Don't try to be energetic. Just just
sit here like I'm on anti-depressants and read the news.
No, dude. NO, NOT THAT. >> PATHETIC. You know, that is
an unproductive expression of anger. Um, it's just stupid. It's
just stupid. I need to grow up uh and just get my [__]
together. You know, it's in general.
>> You know, everybody has their moments of anger,
but like I I really should be better than this. I apparently
I'm not, you know, cuz it's just [__] pathetic. So,
I'm already hap I'm not happy about that in general. That's not
how I really want. >> Okay. No, he just doesn't want to
have any reaction like that in case he is incorrect again. He's
just scared. Yeah, that's a existence that you can't live in.
Okay. You got to That's That's tough, man. Just not wanting to
take like a stance cuz you haven't looked into it enough. That
is a lot of being an influencer is is being willing to like risk
being wrong on stuff and taking strong positions.
If you if you don't pop off ever, then you have no ability to
go like viral. no ability to go and get like your claims out
there. If you never pop off ever, by the way, that makes people
come back to the stream. If they're like, if they're on your
side, if you have them emotionally connected, they're amped up,
that makes them want to come back to the stream, it's a good
time.
I don't He knows this. He has to know this. Just being like,
"Yeah, I'm like totally I should never pop off. I should never
do anything like that. I'm 30." It's like, bro, hang him up.
Hang him up, buddy. >> Want to communicate myself as a
content creator. Uh, I would like to be somebody that's a little
more intelligent. You know, maybe I'm just smart enough but just
dumb enough to think I'm somebody that could be known for being
intelligent. I don't know.
I don't know, man. This kind of communicates that. Um, you know,
but the the crashing out in general is just not how I want to
communicate myself. I think I'd like to think that I have a little
bit more to offer than just unintelligent screaming and rambling.
He's like a [__] Um, so I guess we'll see with the
rest of this year how that
But I >> be more like clvicular. If there was any any advice
I could give Papa, it would be not to mimic Clavvicular. Okay?
You can't be Clavicular. Clavicular can be the calm guy. Okay?
Because there's other elements there that make his stream watchable.
You can't be the calm
All right? Name one fat calm streamer. Name one, a single one.
They don't exist. Okay. >> I do think that I have a little
more to offer and in general, this is not the way that I want
to, you know, communicate myself onto the internet. I think that
like there's more productive ways that I can express myself and
and counteract things that I disagree with. Like a force of Nick
Shirley video. Um, and I simply didn't do that and that was just
me yelling and having like a meltdown and that was childish in
of itself. Again, regardless of whether I'm right or wrong, but
guess what? I was like super wrong. This is embarrassing.
Uh, you know, it is what it is, but I was super wrong. There
was a moment in Nick Shirley's video where he went to I think
it was like 607 Cedar, but it said South Cedar. Uh, and I'm like,
Nick, you're on at the right place, right? Right. And I looked
it up on on
I looked it up and >> Yeah. Yeah. You He knows he's absurd.
The second he says this that he knows he's absurd. Avoiding the
puddle. Aris crashes out all the time. What are you talking about?
Aerys crashes out calmly. So maybe I'll give you that. But also
his camera is not the main feature of the stream. He's very funny
also. But he knows that he's about to sound insane. I looked
it up on Map Quest. I looked it up on Map Quest. He's about to
say it. He'll know. He knows I sound totally when I say that.
>> But I found it on map quests. I got I'm just gonna show
you because it's so embarrassing.
You know, for me it's like I've done that before where I've like
forgot to put like the north in and I go to a completely different
place. Uh you know, and so I was like, "Wait a minute." You know,
I I'm an idiot, but let me just show you. So yeah, I got everything
on the screen now. Um so this is where Nick Shirley was 607.
Realistically, by the way, the biggest crime here, the absolute
biggest crime, bar none, is that Papa Gut, this loser, handed
Nick Shirley a W.
He had That's the actual problem, okay? Why you should be about
this, why you should be annoyed is glue eating Nick Shirley gets
to hold a W because this fat, okay? That's that's what you should
actually be mad about. That's what you should actually be upset
about. That is the downside. That is the problem. Okay?
Why are you attacking Nick versus the message? Because Nick Shirley
is a glue
Nick Shirley is a total spur who is incapable of forming sentences
unless he's on script. Nick Shirley is the dumbest I've ever
seen make any serious YouTube video essay ever. He is like the
lowest IQ person I've ever seen make like that level of pop off
YouTube documentary.
What do you mean? Why am I attacking Nick Shirley? Nick Shirley
is a complete He is a mouth breather. You are so mad. Have you
ever watched this guy speak anywhere? Chooch.
Have you ever watched this guy speak off the cuff anywhere? Hold
on. Uh, let me load up the balevolent post. Wait, hold on. Nick
Shirley
interview.
Let's go find the benevolent. >> A lot of billionaires
are trying to make a lot of change here in this worldly.
>> But you think closing the border will make it so has
increased the >> I think so. I think a lot of billionaires
are trying to make billionaires and I think there's good billionaires
in the NGOs's. I don't think so. I think there's all there's
bad billionaires and I think there's good billionaires in this
world and I think uh >> a lot of billionaires are trying
to make a lot of change here in this world. >> You're so
mad at him for exposing the fraud and directing everything to
attacking him versus the fraud. Nope. You're actually totally
wrong and you haven't watched my coverage of the fraud because
I actually read the 2019 report and I have the actual opinion
that you should have and you're a [__] Okay. If you
think Nick Shirley did anything positive, he is a complete. He
made sure none of those Somalian thieves will ever be caught.
That's all Nick Shirley did. He's a complete [__]
There's no fraud according to you. Okay, call in. Call in. There's
no fraud according to you. This guy's a
There's a word for people like you. Okay, you're slur. I absolutely
think there's fraud. I've gone to the painstaking length. I'VE
GONE TO PAINSTAKING LENGTHS TO SHOW how there is fraud. This
guy is a complete.
Now watch him try to say benevolent and not know the word. >> I
think they create a lot a lot of opportunity. You talk about
Amazon. Well, Amazon also employs
what do you mean by the word benev here inside the United States?
>> Who do you think are the three most benevolent billionaires?
>> What do you mean by the word benevolent?
what do you mean by the word benevolent? What do you mean by
the word benevolent? What do you mean
>> this glue eating is who you worship? You think this
guy does journalism? You think he's not just handed a script
and told what to say? This guy is completely
>> well-intentioned positive. >> God, that that's
who you're sweeping for right now. This complete I can see why,
by the way, I have you ignored on my chat overlay because you
yourself are also at this level of IQ. That's why you look up
to this guy because you are actually at this guy's level of IQ.
Yeah, you're totally wrong. You don't know my pos. You don't
know my position on the fraud. You don't know the tweets I've
made about it. You don't know anything about it at all. You're
a completely deaf, dumb, blind scrap. like just running your
fingers over the walls of this chat trying to figure out what
to do. Okay, you have no senses. You have nothing going on in
your life. I don't know what your purpose is, but please by all
means continue to say things in my chat, the KCIP chat, you know,
frequency. It helps. So, thank you. I appreciate you. Okay, you're
going to get people typing in chat.
>> You want you want to do that with your life? That's
great. >> Ruben donated $3. >> Hello. Hello. >> Show
mercy. After all, you are a belent god. I am a benevolent god.
I am. That's true. That is true. We will show mercy while KCI
volume. >> Um, as you can see, this is I also had this
map quest pulled up and it's of the uh Oromo.
>> Um, Chooch, I want you to tell me if you put energy
into figuring out why there's fraud. I want you to tell me what
the number one recommendation of the 2019 report was into this
fraud.
Since you've since you've done so much work, go ahead, tell me
what was the number one recommendation.
You surely know about the 2019 report, right? You surely know
about this whole soggy. Surely you've put some work in. You you've
read some [__] right?
Yeah. Okay. Yeah, that's that's all you need to see. I would
highlight that message for everybody so you can see it on screen.
But unfortunately, this guy is literally removed from my chat
overlay probably for saying incredibly things that I wanted to
ignore during stream. Resource Center of Minneapolis, which has
been closed for
>> He just said, "I don't watch a Well, I guess thank you
for saying I'm not a
I don't know who else you could possibly be talking about, but
>> a while now. Or rather, it it shut down this location
and they moved. So, >> uh anyway, I'm looking at the difference
between this map and Google Maps and I'm like, "Wow, this looks
really different." Um I don't know if you guys know it, it's
not. It just looks different. So, basically, I got I allowed
myself to get tricked by something a third grader would get tricked
by.
>> Uh, okay. It's It's Discord time. You can hop in the
Discord. You can come argued on stream right now. Come argue
free to come argued on stream. Otherwise, come back tomorrow,
>> which is Wow. See, this is different from the It's not
It's simply not. It's simply not different. >> We're locked
in. >> Uh, so, you know, I thought it was um again, to
their credit, I guess, you know, this could be fraud. It seems
like there used to be a resource center here and uh it looks
like they had originally filed to that resource center. It inevitably
shut down and and moved and they just had not updated their location
or it could be fraud. I don't know. Like I mean like we're at
this point. Um like you can see down here after Shirley's video
they looks like they changed they changed their address to something
else,
So you know it could be just a simple clerical error. It could
be fraud. I don't know. But either way it's not really what it's
about, is it? is about me being a idiot and being like, "Wait,
>> I think it's just weird to me that there are a lot of
streamers who could look into this, who don't look into this,
who just decide they're not going to care, right?" But sorry,
they're going to care and that they'll attack Nick Shirley or
they'll attack the idea that there's fraud and they won't go
and look deeper and see that this has been a pervasive problem
in Minnesota that they've been trying to address for a long time.
And probably the real enemy here is like how slow government
is. that government cannot move at the pace current society moves
at and that our government is like failing us in in a multitude
of ways. That's the real problem, okay, is that they they actually
passed like some ideas to to try to get less of this fraud happening
and they passed them as in they were going to be implemented
in 5 years in the future. Like, dude, that's that's insane. >> That
the wrong place because the maps look different. It's just different
maps. Like, well, who would have thought that different maps
would look different, right? And so, I had this whole like, oh,
he's in the wrong place. say he's being dishonest.
Very, again, very unproductive. Um, I mean, cuz I have some valid
criticis criticisms, excuse me, of Nick Shirley, you know, like
for instance, uh, why didn't he just call the numbers on the
sign to see if he could get little Shirley in
to the daycare? We didn't see that in his video. It feels intentional.
Why didn't he show up when the daycarees were opening um to see
if kids were going in there? It kind of feels intentional, you
know, that would be
either way. Like, that's not really the point of this video.
this one of his videos that I well mostly to put an apology to
Caleb Hammer. Um, but there are like a lot of different things
I I have an issue with and obviously this
I haven't seen one streamer not note the actual fraud other than
IRI and they all bring up the fact that Oh, but hold on. That's
not this fraud though, Simpo. That's not this fraud. That's not
the child care ccap fraud.
That's different fraud, right? That's the feeding our future
or whatever. >> I look so fun. I look so funny here. I
look so good. Makes me look like a [__] Let's be
real. Um, I scrolled through this video. I didn't notice it.
>> That's why that's why it's important to see why would
people think this? Why did they think they could make a video
like this? Why is there But because there's a whole thing underlying
this, that if you look into it, it's obvious there are multiple
problems, right? And that Nick Shirley's video, by the way, if
Nick Shirley had been aware of that report, he would have known
how to actually prove that there's fraud here because they talk
about it. They talk about how they prove fraud in these cases.
>> There's something in here at some point that just says
Papa Gut's fat and dumb or something. Papa Gut is an idiot in
the It's the same. It's true. I am an idiot. I mean, what else?
>> He did Shimu call him fat or is he just making that
up? Is he just seeing fat allegations everywhere? >> I
was going to say I got nothing here. I'm pathetic.
So, that's that part. That's embarrassing. Like, I got something
so wrong in the crash out. But frankly, I I'm not trying to be
I don't really like I care about those things. But the reason
I really feel like I want to talk about this is cuz like I like
I
like like I say some really nasty stuff about a friend of mine
like and uh I've been kind of thinking like why why would I do
that? Um you know Caleb is like a legitimate friend of mine >> we've
been friends for like a while you know uh and he reached out
to me. He saw like a video of mine that he appreciated and he
reached out to me and we've been chatting here and there ever
since. and like you know he's come on and like talked to me for
my platform and I've gone on to his live platform when I disagreed
with something.
I mean he's been nothing but uh he's been like nothing but like
a nice guy.
>> Dude, that's actually thinking about I'm actually really
like what an I'm actually really upset about it. Uh he's been
nothing but a good guy like even when we disagree
you know and uh last time we had a disagreement over like you
know oh I felt like he was going a little too far right. Okay.
So, I made a video about it and he watched it and he's like,
"Hey, you want to come on the show and we talk about it?" And
it's like, you know,
I allowed myself to blow up? Like, how unreasonable. What kind
of a person? Why would you even bother watching me as a content
creator if I did? He try to make this as gay as possible so I'd
click away. You're not going to put You're not going to push
me off here, okay? You're not going to push me away from reacting
to this just because you make this video incredibly gay and annoying
to watch. Okay. >> I do that. And I've been trying to think
like why why did I do that? like why would I allow myself to
be so pathetic. Um
you know I'm not 20 anymore.
You know back then being emotional and shooting from the cuff
is you know almost like oh yeah you're 20. You're dumb. I'm 35.
Why would I do that? So I've been thinking about it talking to
my wife about it. You know it's not exactly the easiest thing
in the world to be aware of yourself to that degree of like why
exactly am I engaging in such behavior? And uh you know I've
a little soulsearching and so in general like I'm generally frustrated
and I think the frustration's valid but the disproportionate
expression of that frustration and anger is disgusting.
Um but like I'm frustrated with this general administration.
You know I know there's a lot of people who wouldn't resonate
with that message. Um they wouldn't be like oh that makes sense.
You especially on Twitter. >> Why do I feel like he's had
this exact monologue several other times in his life? Yeah, I
do get the feeling that that that is the feeling you get. Apparently,
he had some big controversy about some adjacent commentary made.
Old enough to bleed, old enough to breed, I think is is what
he said, and he got cancelled for it,
which I mean, Jesus, that's what happens when you run the super
lefty spaces, okay? No edge. No edge is allowed. >> But
for me, it's been very frustrating since he got elected. You
know, when he got elected the first when Trump specifically were
talking about when he got elected the first time, I was like,
"Okay, let's see how this goes." And it didn't seem to be super
productive. You know, we ended up voting him out in the midterms.
Uh, and this time around it's been like more frustrating. There's
been there's a lot of things that are that have been very frustrating.
You know, the most recent stuff like the the con well really
the constant threat of our allies, you know, some unnecessary
tariffs for instance for like with Canada and I'm going to overexlain
just so that you know where I'm coming from for people who don't
get it. And I know the Canada thing was like last year, but there's
been so many controversies that just rolling by. It all feels
like a distraction for like the epine >> dude
that he promised to release and and >> is this just like
an incredibly low energy die tribe about the state of politics
failed as an apology.
Listen guys, you can understand why I feel this way because like
the tariffs in Canada and people sweeping for it and like feels
like a distraction from the Epstein f what the is this man?
never really released them and seems like there's controversy
after controversy. Uh, every single time, you know, it's it's
hey, you got Hey, what's going on with that? All of a sudden
there's a new controversy. But, you know, him blaming Ukraine
for starting the war. Um, him going after Greenland, uh, him
tariffing a bunch of countries like Canada for instance, that,
you know, if you look at the numbers, they actually spend more
on American goods per person, they're a smaller country, than
we do on Canadian goods. And it's like, we're going after all
these partners and these allies and, you know, we're destroying
those. where, you know, ICE is crazy, violating people's due
process. Um, you know, speed up. Holy [__] >> Watching
like a George uh, you know, speech about um, illegal immigration
and I totally agree with, I guess, Republicans used to feel,
which like, hey, illegal immigration problem. We have to have
deal with it, but we have to have deal with some, I guess, nuance
because these are still people who are coming here to do jobs.
Um, and we have dependency on them because they do jobs that
Americans don't want to do and we need to be delicate and not
demonize. But, the Trump administration has been very much dehumanizing,
you know, legal immigrants. They're people. So, you know, I can
respect somebody trying to do their best to protect their family
and that's frustrating. That's very frustrating for me especially.
Um, you know, and so there's a lot of going on. There's been
a lot of you know the whole situation where Mark Kelly told um
different law enforcement agents that they don't have to listen
to legal orders and the Trump administration trying to take away
veterans stuff like that's a violation of freedom of speech that's
free speech a lot of things have been working out and I think
it's valid that I'm frustrated and I think for the most part
I'm expressing
>> dude
it's totally valid that you're frustrated I would just it's about
making a false claim and perhaps you're letting your like your
emotion cloud where you're going with your claims. Right. This
is a this is an indicator. It was lucky for him that he did it
to a friend. He didn't like totally make up some misinformation
that people carried forward and like propagated. He's lucky that
it was so obvious here, right? Not something that could catch
him later.
This guy became an Ethan orbiter after seeing the Ryan Beard
video. His political takes are literally just soy destiny. Excuse
me. Expressing that frustration productively. Um except this
time, you know, and
somehow in my head I'm like, does wouldn't Britney Simon have
told him about Destiny? Wasn't he like whatever? >> That's
how it works, isn't it? It's like, you know, you got a little
bit of an anger problem a little bit. I guess I understand. I
mean, I thought I had under control. Um, I think it's one I mostly
did, but it's where you have like a valid thing to be upset about
and then you just let it explode and you express it productively
and specifically in Caleb's case because I really have been thinking
about it. Um, I've been seeing a couple clips here and there
of some few things, mostly his clips like what he's putting out
there or a little bit of his coverage and you know, obvious
blah blah blah. And I remember him saying the other, you know,
think I'm going to I'll talk to him when I feel like it's more
more of a productive time. Just really putting it off and avoiding
talking about what I really was just like, you know, if I have
a disagreement or if I think I think I have a disagreement,
um, just DM him or not, excuse me, just react to something on
my stream. That's what I do for a living. I can just react to
be like, oh, hey, this is wrong. Hey, oh, this is wrong. Maybe
I'm wrong. Maybe I'm wrong by the way. I I look at his content.
I don't know because I didn't just do that, but I like avoiding
it. >> Oh, this is what I was fishing for. Britney did
and he ignored her. That's what wrecked their friendship. Okay.
>> I think part of his friend I don't want to criticize
him maybe in some instances, which is something that's like embarrassing
to them as well cuz you know, um, and I think part of it's like,
okay, I think there can be a more productive moment or maybe
I want to have like a more perfect moment, but I'm not doing
like my due diligence. I'm not even fully I didn't fully watch
this coverage of certain things that I'm frustrated about. And
I kind of just put it off instead of just like, okay, I'm going
to watch this. Let me watch this. Let me see what I just didn't,
you know, I avoided it. um for you know one reason or the other.
You know part of me like I don't want to harass him because we
already just talked live someone recently like a couple maybe
a month ago but either way either way. >> Okay. Now I've
upgraded the most offensive thing about this is how low energy
he is in this entire response such that even if I'm getting like
angry at him and yelling at him the whole time I'm still going
to lose audience. Okay. You're so boring right now. You're so
low energy in this response. You're like making the perfect anti-react
content.
Uh, listen, note to self, if you ever have to make an apology,
just talk in a super slow cadence, bring up totally irrelevant
stuff and say how like, listen, I think you guys should like
be understanding of how my, you know, I got here and even though
it's not okay that I got here this way, I think it's understandable
that I got here and so I should maybe in the future with people
I like, I to do my due diligence
>> way for you know different reasons I decided not to
and of course
>> uh you know I guess I'm going to say >> script
something script something if you're going to come on and apologize
script something >> regardless of how I say it so instead
of a productive like oh I'm going to watch this and do something
and he watches my content so he may have watched it I mean there's
a good chance he would watch it be like oh I see where you're
coming from if it was great so that I just bottled it up and
then this was my moment of exposure in the middle of the stream
I've seen this next thing someone's like oh did you see what
Caleb had to say about it I turn it on I see like very little
bit and I [__] go off and and just disgusting um
it's shameful especially because again it's a friend of mine
what does the matter with you and it's like I just went off,
man. Very unproductively, very unintelligently, very weak. I
say some really nasty things. Um, I say some really nasty things,
man. Like, what a piece of I'm just like because I'm thinking
about it. I'm not going to rewatch myself saying this stuff.
That's embarrassing. But I'm thinking like what did I say? I'm
like little things. I was like, holy, I said this. Damn. Like,
what kind of a person? >> That's the roughest part. Okay,
you do need to watch yourself a little bit. >> It's like
a friend. It's like, holy, it was like so black and white. >> I'm
getting like bored with this. Whatever. I don't know if there's
much more here. I'm getting kind of bored with it. We got three
minutes. Maybe we'll finish these three minutes. Now, next, what
do we want to do next? We could go to watching some of the Dioro
stream on Turkey Tom. See how that coverage is going. There is
that. There is also the whole thing. Last night, there was a
very funny thing with um Food Shops and Darius and Parseek, these
people. And I if I could get the story behind that, I'd be like
interested. I I turned on I saw food shops stream title and it
was like really funny.
Okay. It was it was like kind of funny to me
and I actually clicked on it and then I walked away from my computer
and I was like doing dishes and stuff. I was like trying to clean
up in my house and I forgot I had the stream on. She was taking
like five minute five minute silence breaks to message like Destiny's
Reddit mod cuz apparently she said there was like revenge recordings
of her put up on Darius's stream or something and like she was
getting Dude, there's like a whole drama there. I would need
to work it out. I know the gist of it. I know pretty much what's
going on. But
by the way, that didn't happen.
Like she'd given another streamer permission to put those recordings
out. like she she had actually said you can play that you could
play all this stuff on stream
and so there's like a reason to believe that she had given position
yeah sorry she'd given not position she'd given um the okay to
morale to play those but then I think she didn't want him to
play them so like afterwards she was like wait why did you play
that stuff and he was like well look you said I could anyway
I might I might think about going through that stuff if I could
if I find it I might think about going through it because I I
do find it interesting that
I think they banned they banned Darius's in bed from DGG. I think
they banned his in bed,
which I didn't realize
that looks like it hurts. >> Uh, you know, in that moment
like I was so intense. I felt so like justified, you know, but
I wasn't at all. But I felt that way. I let myself get to a point
where I felt justified in being a nasty person. And u, you know,
I just, like I said before, like I've already like talked to
banned his in bed then unbanned. It see was supposed to be for
three days, but then they unbanned apology in private, but like
it's not he Well, did they unban it because
food shops like kind of lied or what is the what happened there?
>> And now he might have um you know and it's like damn
like even if we're friends from moving forward like there's
you know I mean I definitely stressed the relationship like what
a piece of you know I'm a grown man and uh you know Caleb even
says like oh I appreciate your takes and the way they talk about
stuff I was like what the how did I do this though? This is crazy.
This is like I don't know. Sorry I'm just I don't know. as I'm
recording it, I'm like, I said it again more. You know, I've
been kind of like mentally and emotionally putting it off and
thinking about it, but like now that I'm saying it out loud,
it's like, "Oh, Jesus." [__] man. >> So, more
than anything else, um, you know, this is more of an apology
to >> And like I said, apologies public, but now everything's
public. So, like, a public apology is obviously warranted.
>> that's that's what I care about the Again, like I had
nothing that wasn't good. I got something wrong. That's stupid.
But I I I put a I put trust in a friendship with somebody who's
been like really nice to me and who's like sat down with me and
given me advice. >> Okay. Okay. I'm getting some caffeine
and I'm getting ready to go with more content. Guys, if you like
the content so far, go ahead. Throw a couple kicks my way. Throw
a couple subs my way. Let's uh
let's try to make it a long stream, okay? If you like the content,
add some more time. You go through kicks, you go through subs.
I'm going to let this video finish. I'm going to use the bathroom,
get a drink, and then we're on to the Nicholas Yoro stuff. Watching
his review, a little bit of the review of the Turkey Tom stuff,
and we'll cover Turkey update as well. Okay, there are Turkey
Tom updates. There is more content there. We will be doing the
Turkey Tom updates right after this. Your volume is much lower
than the contents. Well, it shouldn't be. Hold on. May it might
have been that I was looking away from my mic. I was not talking
into my mic. So, that's probably what it was was me looking away
from my clearly directional mic. Okay.
All right. All right. >> Yeah, dude. Like, what the wrong
with me? What a piece of dog. So, um you know, I'm going to upload
this video on YouTube and Twitter and I'm going to say like Caleb,
take a look. And I'm going to be honest cuz I got to say this
now. I'm just like embarrassed of myself as Like I don't even
know if I can I can talk to Caleb for a while for myself cuz
I'm so embarrassed. Like what did I do? Uh and you know it's
like damn. And then imagine Caleb's like yeah man like it was
[__] up but I uh you know it is what it is. I app
you know we're still friends. Like that's so like I just cuz
that's probably somewhat around what he'll you know it's like
like this guy's going to be nice to me after I was such an abysmal
piece of dog. Such a rude nasty. Goddamn you know like I'm supposed
to be better than that. Obviously I'm not. Yeah. You know I mean
all I can really say is sorry [__] up man. Like holy
[__] that's such a piece of I'm sorry at this point.
I'm just kind of talking to talk to the almost vent, but it's
supposed to be a as short and sweet as possible video. I think
we're like 15 minutes now. So, um, you >> I don't have
my caffeine. I don't have my caffeine yet. I got I'm going to
have to walk away. But he's not addressing the actual worst part
of this. The actual worst part of this is that you played into
every piece of conservative propaganda that exists about how
libs get super emotional and they'll attack things without looking
into it. Right. Look at the came into my chat and thought I was
like against the Nick Shirley thing. You you played exactly precisely
into that narrative that libs are like emotional who can't control
themselves and will scream at you without understanding anything.
You played in that stereotype precisely. Nick Shirley gets a
massive W on you. 14,000 likes there. Shimoo gets a popup tweet.
Okay. I think Shimu talked about this as well. He tried to make
it he knew he was getting it from like a lefty community so he
tried to make it more right leaning. Dude,
I it's so annoying that he hands Nick Shirley this massive W.
There's just no reason to do that, man. That's the most annoying
thing to me. And he hasn't even apologized to me. Apologize to
me, okay? I'm the most important person here. Apologize to me.
What the man? All right, I just need to grab some water for my
caffeine stuff and I'll be right >> You know, um I guess
everyone watching that saw the crash out, you know. I'm ashamed
of myself. Sorry to you guys. But again, more than anything else,
sorry to Gale and the crew really. Um and if this is the end
of the friendship, I totally understand. You know, what the [__]
else am I going to What else am I going to say? I [__]
up. So, you know, I'm probably going to isolate myself in general
a little right now when I get frustrated and I do something.
I like to isolate and just kind of be myself. Um, I'm obviously
on stream my job. I probably I might even finish this [__]
Shirley video. I don't know if I'm productive. I don't listen
to anymore, but hey, the show must go on. So, um, thanks for
listening to me rant, guys. And again, I'm so sorry to Caleb
and crew. I think the crew also deserves apology, you know, cuz
I said some just nasty things in general. Like, what a [__]
me, man. All right. Well, um, God bless. Love you. Bye. also
probably revalidated
Caleb sorry Caleb Hammer's view of the world that he thinks he
needs to be the centrist like enlightened centrist for everything
probably hardcore reeal like sorry um doubled him down on that
pretty stupid pretty God.